[Musik]
am 20 oktober 2011 wurde der lübische
Staatschef mamad Gaddafi gefangen
genommen und getötet und wie ihr wisst
wurde er nicht gerade auf eine
zivilisierte Art und Weise hingerichtet
aber ob er es verdient hat oder nicht
das überlasse ich euch tatsache ist dass
Gaddafis Tod das Ende von fast 42 Jahren
einer eisernen Herrschaft markiert nach
2011 hat sich Libyen massiv verändert
wahrscheinlich für immer das Problem ist
allerdings dass dieser Wechsel nicht
gerade eine vielversprechende Situation
hinterlassen hat denn Seiter ist es mit
dem Land immer weiter den Bach
runtergegangen 22 August 2023 un die
Stabilität Libyens ist nach tödlichen
Zusammenstößen von Milizen und Unruhen
in Niger und Sudan stark gefährdet 12
September 2023 weltweite Ölpreise
erreichen nach Flutkatastrophe in Libyen
10 Monats hoch 22 September 2023 die
überlebenenden der libischen Flut stehen
vor einem Trauma mindestens 4000
Menschen sollen bei dem Unwetter in
Derna ums Leben gekommen sein in der 1en
Septemberwoche zog der Sturm Daniel über
das Mittelmeer und verursachte riesige
Überschwemmungen in Libyen die Zahl der
Todesopfer ging in die Tausende
natürlich ist dies aber nur die jüngste
in einer endlosen Reihe von Katastrophen
und Unglücken die die Libyer in den
letzten Jahren durchmachen mussten der
Sturz des Gaddafi Regimes führte zu
einem zweiten Bürgerkrieg und einem
gewaltigen Chaos aber was genau ist
eigentlich nach dem Sturz gadfis
passiert warum ist lbien deswegen im
tiefsten Chaos versunken und wird sich
das Land in den kommenden Jahren wieder
erholen können all das werden wir in
diesem Video genau unter die Lupe nehmen
denn Libyen könnte sich für Europa zu
einem sehr sehr wichtigen
Energielieferanten entwickeln das
heutige Video hat übrigens unser treuer
Sponsor schark möglich gemacht und
deswegen müssen wir euch unbedingt noch
sein spezielles Winterangebot vor
stellen denn solltet ihr noch kein VBN
haben ist dies nun eine super
Gelegenheit so günstig wie nur selten
dran zu kommen wusstet ihr z.B dass
viele Firmen wie Social Airlines online
ganz unterschiedliche Preise anbieten
können je nachdem von welchem Land aus
man bestellt bzw sein Ticket Bucht aber
zum Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe eines
VPNs überlisten und dann richtig Geld
sparen surshark VPN ist dabei ein
wirklich empfehlenswertes und sicheres
VPN welches z.B keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mitlockt eine Virtual
Private networkp B ist aber nicht nur
zum Geld sparen geeignet es kann einen
auch vor so manch größer Gefahr schützen
die eben n lauert natürlich muss man
nach wie vor Umsicht walten lassen und
wissen was man tut aber es stellt
hierfür ein Werkzeug mit gleich mehreren
Vorteilen da zum einen erschwert es in
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen e
Aktion im Netz nachzuverfolgen und
abzuhören mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheitsfeatures könnt ihr so eure
anonität im Netz erhöhen z.B mit dem
integrierten cleanwb das alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Pop-ups blockt
weiterer Vorteil ein VP ist dass ihr so
tun könnt als wäret ihr an einem anderen
Ort so könnt ihr z.B auf Webseite und
Internetdienste zugreifen in dem Land in
dem ihr gerade seit nicht verfügbar
wären ob daheim oder im Urlaub damit
schlagt der Zensur geoblocking ein
Schnippchen Netflix und andere Streaming
die ihre Inhalte nur in den USA Anbieten
von Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshar kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles denn mit nur einem
surfchar Konto könnt ihr wirklich alle
eure Endgeräte im vpin registrieren
Handys Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart
TV so und wenn ihr den Rabattcode
politikd angeht bekommt ihr von zu
aufchag im Rahmen dieses speziellen
winterangebots auch noch zusätzlich sech
Monate gratis dazu den Link zu diesem
Angebot findet dir in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video also nichts wie los
besorgt euch suragung soft ab jetzt
sicher und ohne diskriminiert zu werden
im
[Musik]
Internet meine Lieben Zuschauer manchmal
kann sich die Geschichte viel stärker
wiederholen als wir uns das überhaupt
vorstellen können wie dieses
Paradebeispiel zeigt am 4 mai 1980
verstarb Jos Pros Tito der
unangefochtene Führer des großen
Jugoslawiens sein Tod löste eine
Vielzahl ethnischer und politischer
Spannungen auf dem Balkan aus die
wirklich schlimm endeten das Ableben
Titos führte also zum Zerfall
Jugoslawiens und einer Vielzahl von
Konflikten mit blutigen Kriegen aber
Moment mal sollte das hier nicht ein
Video über Libyen sein nun keine Angst
uns geht es nämlich darum dass der Sturz
und die Ermordung gadfis zu einem sehr
ähnlichen Szenario in Libyen geführt hat
ihr müsst nämlich verstehen dass Libyen
ein ziemlich komplexes Land ist es setzt
sich aus mehreren Fraktionen
verschiedener Stämme und etnie zusammen
ähnlich wie das ehemalige Jugoslawien
wir sprechen sogar von mehr als 30
Stämmen und Familienclans die in der
Vergangenheit großen Einfluss auf die
Politik des Landes hatten und was all
diese Gruppen in den letzten fünf
Jahrzehnten zusammenhielt war zum einen
das System der eisernen Faust das das
Land beherrschte und zum anderen der
riesige Apparat aus Vergünstigungen
Privilegien und ölpopulismus unter der
Führung von Gaddafi ihr wisst schon die
gute alte Politik von Zuckerbrot und
Peitsche doch nach Gaddafis Ableben
verschwanden auch all diese Stabilität
und Harmonie die mit dem Ölgeld erkauft
worden waren es gab kein Übergang und
das Land stürzte ins völlige Chaos
erklären lässt sich das in etwa
folgendermaßen dieme Sekten aus denen
diese eher günstlichen Staaten bestehen
wurden lange Zeit durch eine eiserne
Faust von Kolonialmächten Königen oder
militärdiktatoren zusammen gehalten sie
sind keine echten Bürger im modernen
Sinne demokratische Machtwechsel sind
unmöglich weil jeder Stamm nach dem
Motto herrsche oder stirb lebt entweder
ist mein Stamm oder meine Sekte an der
Macht oder wir sind tot aber was genau
geschah nach dem Sturz des großen
Führers des arabischen Sozialismus nun
das werden wir gleich
herausfinden
vom erfolgreichen Start bis zur
Bruchlandung im Jahr 2011 brach in
Tunesien der arabische Frühling aus ein
Prozess politischer Proteste der sich
schnell in ganz Nordafrika und Teilen
des Nahen Ostens ausbreitete Libyen
bildete da keine Ausnahme plötzlich
wurden große Demonstration und Proteste
gegen die Regierung entfesselt eine
Bewegung die sich schließlich zu einem
echten Bürgerkrieg entwickelte am 26
Februar 2011 beschloss der
Sicherheitsrat der Vereinten Nationen
das Vermögen der lbischen Regierung
einzufrieren und ein Waffenembargo gegen
das Land zu verhängen später am 17 März
genehmigte er auch die Einrichtung einer
Flugverbotszone die angeblich Zivilisten
in den rebellengebieten vor
Luftangriffen der lübischen Streitkräfte
schützen sollte diese beiden
Resolutionen wurden von Frankreich und
Großbritannien vorangetrieben aber weder
Russland noch China legten ihr Veto ein
mit anderen Worten die ganze Welt wandte
sich gegen Gaddafi und tatsächlich war
es kurz darauf die NATO höchstpönlich
die in diesen Konflikt Eingriff um die
militärischen Fähigkeiten des Regimes in
Tripolis zu vernichten und wie ihr
bereits wisst fiel das Regime
schließlich im Oktober desselben Jahres
wurde Gaddafi gefangen genommen
gefoltert und hingerichtet libyen wurde
vom sogenannten Nationalen Übergangsrat
geführt dieses Gremium hatte 10 Monate
lang die Kontrolle inne seine Aufgabe
war klar das Land zu stabilisieren und
Wahlen zu organisieren die eine neue
demokratische Phase einleiten sollten li
Büren ist ein unabhängiger
demokratischer Staat in dem das Volk die
Quelle der Macht ist die Stadt Tripolis
soll die Hauptstadt des Staates sein der
Islam ist die Religion der Staates und
die Hauptquelle der Gesetzgebung ist die
islamische Rechtssprechung Sharia der
Staat garantiert den nichtmoslims die
Freiheit religiöse Rituale zu
praktizieren arabisch ist se Amtssprache
der Staat garantiert die kulturellen
Rechte für alle Teile der libischen
Gesellschaft und seine Sprachen gelten
als nationale Sprachen
verfassungserklärung des
nationalübergangsrats der Rat willigte
ein und im Juli 2012 wurden Wahlen zum
Nationalkongress abgehalten der dann die
Aufgabe hatte einen Premierminister zu
wählen und einen verfassungsgebenden
Prozess einzuleiten an diesen Wahlen
nahmen 61,5% der Wahlberechtigten
libyerinnen und Libyer teil und zu
dieser Zeit sah alles noch recht gut aus
die Aussichten waren recht
vielversprechend ja es gab viele
Spannungen aber in weniger als einem
Jahr war das Land in der Lage gewesen
eine nationale Wahl zu organisieren und
eine Regierung zu bilden und dennoch
hielt der Optimismus ungefähr so lange
wie ein Eis in der
[Musik]
Sahara bei den libischen
Parlamentswahlen 2012 wurde ein System
verwendet das als nicht übertragbare
Einzelstimme bekannt ist das bedeutet
dass die Wähler nur eine einzige Stimme
hatten die sie an einen einzelnen
Kandidaten aus ihrem Wahlkreis abgeben
konnten es gab also nur lokale keine
nationalen Kandidaten und genau das
führte dazu dass viele unabhängige
Politiker gewählt wurden die
untereinander überhaupt keine
Beziehungen hatten das Problem Problem
dabei war dass der Kongress dadurch in
mehrere Monoblöcke aufgeteilt wurde was
die Möglichkeit einschränkte stabile
Mehrheiten zu schaffen und zu erhalten
erschwerend kam hinzu dass alle
möglichen radikalislamischen
Gruppierungen wie z.B da ihre Chance
sahen sie breiteten sich überall aus sie
konnten die Missstände ausnutzen um
Territorium zu gewinnen dennoch wurden
2014 Neuwahlen abgehalten aber bei
diesen Wahlen lag die Wahlbeteiligung
dann nur noch bei haltet euch fest 18%.
tja und kurz darauf brach es zusammen
eine Fraktion der ehemaligen Mitglieder
des Nationalkongresses weigerte sich
schlicht und einfach die Ergebnisse
anzuerkennen und setzte eine
Parallelregierung in Tripolis ein es
handelte sich dabei um die sogenannte
Regierung der nationalen Rettung zur
gleichen Zeit bildete der neugewählte
Kongress eine eigene Regierung in
tubruck einer libischen Stadt an der
Grenze zu
Ägypten und natürlich war die Existenz
von zwei parallelregierungen der Tropfen
der das Fass zum überlaufen brachte die
Spaltung griff auf die Streitkräfte über
und und das Land wurde in einen zweiten
Bürgerkrieg gestürzt wenn wir zu den
internen Kämpfen zwischen Libyern noch
den Aufstieg des sogenannten islamischen
Staates die Bildung autonomer lokaler
Milizen wie der tuarek oder der tubo und
die Ausbreitung syrischer russischer
ägyptischer und türkischer Interessen
hinzufügen wurde Libyen zu einem Ort an
dem jeder gegen jeden kämpfte im Jahr
2015 sah die Karte dieses Landes wie
eines jener puzles aus von denen niemand
auf der Welt weiß wie man es wieder
zusammensetzt ein Puzzle das aus
verschied Regierungen Stämmen und
jihadistischen Gruppen besteht kurzum
die Existenz eines vereinten Libyens
schien der Vergangenheit anzugehören und
es überrascht nicht dass all diese
Zusammenstöße auch Folgen für das größte
Geschäft in diesem Land hatte nämlich
das gute alte schwarze
Gold Libyen verfügt über eine der zehn
größten konventionellen Ölreserven der
Welt und bis zum Ausbruch des arabischen
Frühlings stieg die Förderung stetig an
tja seitdem hat hat sich allerdings
alles geändert wie ihr dieser Grafik
gleicht entnehmen könnt ist die
Produktion in den Jahren 2014 15 und 16
um 75% eingebrochen und obwohl sie sich
seitdem erholt hat liegt sie immer noch
30% unter dem Niveau von 2010 ich hatte
mehr Vertrauen darin dass die Europäer
angesichts der Nähe zu Libyen in die
Folgemaßnahmen investieren würden das
Ausmaß der stammesspaltung in Libyen war
größer als unsere Analysten erwartet
hatten und unsere Fähigkeit dort
irgendeine Struktur aufzubauen mit der
wir interagieren und mit der Ausbildung
und der Bereitstellung von Ressourcen
beginnen konnten brach sehr schnell
zusammen Barack Obama auf jeden Fall
wurde im Dezember 2015 das sogenannte
libische politische Abkommen
unterzeichnet ein vom Sicherheitsrat der
feereinten Nation gefördertes Abkommen
das ein Dialog zwischen den
verschiedenen politischen Gruppierungen
im Land einführte dadurch wurde ein
Friedensprozess in Gang gesetzt und
schließlich gelang es den meisten
Kriegsparteien 2020 sich auf einen
Waffenstillstand zu einigen und ein
Wahlprogramm aufzustellen die neue
Regierung besteht aus einem Präsidialrat
der bisher von Mohammed menpi geführt
wurde und einem Premierminister Abdul
Hamid BBE beide sind seit Februar bzw
März 2021 im Amt ihre Aufgabe war es den
Boden für die Organisation von Neuwahlen
zu bereiten das haben sie allerdings
noch nicht getan die Frage lautet also
warum haben eigentlich noch keine Wahlen
stattgefunden wie ist die Lage in Libyen
heute wer hat überhaupt das sagen nun
passt gut auf denn die Zukunft des
Landes sieht vielleicht gar nicht mal so
anders aus als die
Vergangenheit ein neuer
Anführer der zweite Bürgerkrieg brachte
eine Reihe neuer
Führungspersönlichkeiten hervor darunter
mehrer Zivilisten wie AREF alid naid den
ehemaligen lübischen Botschafter in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten und
Abdul Hamed b b den derzeitigen
Premierminister allerdings bleiben die
Schwerpunkte der Macht vorerst bei Namen
die sich auf die Vergangenheit und nicht
auf die Zukunft beziehen da wäre z.B ein
gewisser Saif alislam Gaddafi na kommt
euch sein Nachname irgendwie bekannt vor
genau es handelt sich um keinen
geringeren als den Sohn Muamar Gaddafis
der im November 2021 angekündigt hat an
den Präsidentschaftswahlen teilnehmen zu
wollen der erstgeborene Sohn des
ehemaligen lübischen Diktators ist seit
dem Sturz seines Vaters eine Art
Puzzelstück in den Verhandlungen
zwischen den verschiedenen Fraktionen
die um die Kontrolle des Landes
kämpfen ihr müsst nämlich verstehen dass
ich alislam Gaddafi in den Händen der
sintanmiliz befand die im Nordwesten
libiens operierte und die sich während
des Zweiten Bürgerkriegs irgendwie auf
keine feste Seite festlegen wollte das
lübische Repräsentantenhaus erwog
jedenfalls ihm im Rahmen des
Friedensprozesses eine Amnestie zu
gewähren aber der Rest der politischen
Akteure in Libyen lehnte diese Option ab
dennnoch wurde er schließlich 2017
freigelassen und sein Verbleib ist
seitem eine Rätsel im Jahr 2021 erschien
er in einer südlibischen Stadt um seine
Kandidatur für das presidentenamt
anzukündigen obwohl er von einem Gericht
in Tripolis zum Tode verurteilt worden
war und der international
Strafgerichtshof selbst einen Haftbefehl
gegen ihn erlassen hatte tja aber so ist
die Lage in Libyen heute
eben am anderen Ende des Spektrums steht
Khalifa belkassim hafter alfani in der
lübischen Politik ein alter
[Musik]
Bekannter diesen ehemaligen armeeoberst
ließ Gaddafi eins selbstverhaften und
ihn ins Exil nachdem er während eines
grenzkonflikts in den 80er Jahren gegen
Rebellengruppen aus dem Chat versagt
hatte natürlich sahhafter 2011 seine
Chance gekommen und kehrte als
flamboyanter Warlord ins Land zurück und
als 2014 der zweite Bürgerkrieg ausbrach
führte er die lybische Nationalarmee
unter der Autorität des gewählten
Repräsentantenhauses an das von der
zweiten Regierung in Tripolis ja nicht
anerkannt wurde hafter ist ein offener
Gegner der derzeitigen Regierung des
nationalen
Übereinkommens 23 Januar 2020 Chalifa
haftar der libische Warlord ist nicht an
einem Kompromiss interessiert der
76-Jährige kriegsher ist bekanntlich
zenkisch und scheint nicht an einer
Einigung interessiert zu sein im April
startete eine offensive zur Einnahme von
Tripolis wenige Stunden nachdem der UN
Generalsekretär Antonio guteresche in
der Hauptstadt gelandet war um eine
Friedenskonferenz vorzubereiten ha
haftarst Truppen gelang es 2019 mit
Unterstützung der russischen
wagnersöldner den ganzen ölreichen Osten
des Landes unter ihre Kontrolle zu
bekommen 2020 stellt haftar Offensive
zwar ein trotzdem scheint er sich nicht
sonderlich für einen demokratischen
Übergang zu engagieren viele sehen ihn
als eines der großen Hindernisse auf
diesem Weg sein Ziel scheint es zu sein
oberster Militärchef ganz Libyens zu
werden und zwar ohne jegliche politische
Kontrolle allerdings gibt es nicht nur
schlechte Nachrichten aus dem Land seit
März 2023 ist nämlich ein Mechanismus
namens 6 + 6 in Kraft bei dem sechs
Mitglieder des lübischen
Repräsentantenhauses und sechs
Mitglieder des hohen Staatsrats der
Regierung die Grundlagen und Bedingungen
für die Durchführung von Wahlen
aushandeln die Kandidatur Seif alislam
Gaddafis wurde vorerst annulliert da die
Teilnahme von gerichtlich Verurteilten
Personen am Wahlprozess nicht möglich
ist und sogar haftar scheint trotz allem
überzeugt worden zu sein 5 September
2023 un-gesamter und haftar sind sich
einig dass der Entwurf des Wahlgesetzes
fertig gestellt werden muss ich habe
mich heute mit Feldmarschall chalifer
Haft dar in basi getroffen wir waren uns
einig dass die Entwürfe für die
Wahlgesetze vom 6+ 6 Ausschuss fertig
gestellt werden müssen und dass günstige
Bedingungen für inklusive nationale
Wahlen in Libyen geschaffen werden
müssen tja und so war es dann auch bis
eine neue Katastrophe hereinbrach und
diese hat die Verhältnisse erstmal
wieder gründlich
verändert
[Musik]
krisengewindler in den 1 September
Wochen 2023 führte der Sturm Daniel in
den einreinerstaaten des Mittelmeer zu
schweren Überschwemmungen in Libyen
brachen durch dieses Phänomen Dämme
zusammen und Flüsse traten über die Ufer
damit ihr euch eine Vorstellung machen
könnt in Orten wie albaida im Nordosten
des Landes fiel in nur 24 Stunden so
viel Regen wie sonst während eines
Zeitraums von 18 Monaten die
Überschwemmungen hinterließen Tausende
von Toten und Vermissten die Gesamtzahl
der Opfer geht in die ztausende in einem
Land in dem es scheint dass es kaum aus
einer Katastrophe herausgekommen schon
wieder in eine noch schlimmere Gerät und
natürlich lief es so ab wie oft wo viele
eine Tragödie sehen fanden andere eine
Gelegenheit chaliferhaftar nutzte die
Gelegenheit um sich beim Volk als
Manager der Rettung zu präsentieren 21
September 2023 Khalifa haftar wird die
Überschwemmungen in Libyen nutzen um
seine Kontrolle zu vertiefen der starke
Mann in Ostlibyen behält nach den
Überschwemmungen die Kontrolle über die
Hilfe die Katastrophe von Derna am 11
September hat die internationale
Aufmerksamkeit erneut auf auf Herrn
hafta und seine sogenannte libische
nationale Armee gelenkt eine
militärkoalition die die östliche Hälfte
des geteilten nordafrikanischen Landes
mit eiserner Faust kontrolliert
heutzutage funktionieren die von diesem
wout kontrollierten Gebiete wie echte
Militärdiktaturen nichts entgeht seiner
Kontrolle und vielleicht sehen
Regierungen wie melonis italienische
haftar deshalb als jemanden an der in
der Lage ist die Migrationsproblematik
im Mittelmeerraum zu stabilisieren und
das obwohl er als eine
Führungspersönlichkeit gilt die nicht
unbedingt stark mit dem Westen verbunden
ist aber wisst ihr was an dieser Stelle
kommt auch Moskau ins Spiel der Kremmel
verfolgt die Situation in Libyen aus
einem ganz bestimmten Grund nämlich
minuziös und dieser Grund heißt
Gas denn wie sich herausstellt verfügt
Libyen nicht nur über Öl sondern auch
über Erdgas was die Erdgasreserven im
Land angeht gehört es sogar zur Top 20
weltweit dennoch konnten die Gasexporte
nicht einmal 50% des Niveaus vor dem
Sturz Gaddafis
erreichen Libyen braucht mehr
internationale Partner zur Steigerung
der Öl- und Gasproduktion wir haben
immer noch Felder die noch erforscht
werden müssen einschließlich derer im
Mittelmeer und in den zentralen Regionen
wo neue Öl- und Gasfelder entdeckt
wurden libyen hat sich zu einem
wichtigen erdgaslieferanten für Europa
entwickelt nachdem die russischen
Exporte nach dem Einmarsch in der
Ukraine eingestellt wurden ein neues
stabiles Libyen das mit Brüssel
verbündet ist wäre daher ein neuer
Energiepartner der den europäischen
Gasbedarf decken könnte und das liegt
natürlich nicht im Interesse Vladimir
Putins und genau aus diesem Grund
unterstützt Russland haftar während die
USA und andere europäische Staaten über
die UN die Regierung der nationalen
Eintracht und ihr Streben nach Wahlen
unterstützen 29 September 2023
ostlibiens machthaberhaftar trifft Putin
in Moskau aber natürlich wisst ihr dass
Politik nun mal Politik ist deshalb gibt
es bereits Kontakte zwischen Washington
und haftar um kurzfristig böse
Überraschung zu vermeiden und
tatsächlich hat Khalifa haftar in der
Vergangenheit selbst mit der CIA
zusammengearbeitet und sogar die US
Staatsbürgerschaft angenommen und jetzt
scheint der alte Kriegsherr bei den
Wahlen einen Kompromiss eingehen zu
wollen ihm ist vor allem wichtig
sicherzustellen dass einer seiner Söhne
kandidieren kann na ja Familienpolitik
nach lübischer Art ein Klassiker eben
meine Lieben Zuschauer die letzten 12
Jahre waren äußerst hart für die Libyer
vom Arabischen Frühling voller
demokratischen Idealismus ist heute
wenig bis gar nichts übrig geblieben das
Scheitern des übergangsplans und die
wachsende Rolle eines militärischen
Kriegsherren der Ordnung im Tausch gegen
Freiheit verspricht verheißt nichts
Gutes für die Zukunft des
Landes 22 Januar 2024 werden Proteste
und slegungen die libischen
energieambitionen gefährden die
vorübergehende Schließung des größten
libischen Ölfeldes aufgrund von
Protesten in diesem Monat unterstreicht
den anhaltenden Schatten der politischen
Instabilität auf die angeschlagene Öl-
und Gasindustrie des nordafrikanischen
Landes der Militärbefehlshaber
Feldmarschall Khalifa haftar desessen
Streitkräfte den ölreichen Osten libens
kontrollieren organisierte in diesem
Jahr eine Blokade der Felder und Hefen
was die libische nationale
Ölgesellschaft dazu veranlasste die
Exporte aufgrund höherer Gewalt zu
stoppen nach den verheerenden
Überschwemmungen die das Land im
September letzten Jahres heimsuchten
erklärte der IWF dass die
mittelfristigen wirtschaftsaussuchten
Libyens aufgrund der hohen Ölpreise
weiterhin positiv sein und aus diesem
Grund werden wir euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden halten also vergesst bitte
nicht unseren zu abonnieren unbedingt
mit Glöckchen um keines unserer
spannenden Videos zu verpassen und wenn
ihr das erledigt habt würde mich erstmal
eure Meinung zu diesem Thema
interessieren war die Therapie für die
Libyer schlimmer als die Krankheit
glaubt ihr dass es unter Gaddafi besser
gelaufen wäre und welche Zukunft seht
ihr für dieses Land wie immer sind wir
auf eure Diskussion schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt uns bitte ein Like Teil mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert es auch mit
ihnen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jeder seit über eine Spende euch mit
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung dem
Video macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald